[Musique]
c'est le couple qui fait le plus parler
cette saison dans l'amour est dans le
pré
l'agriculteur de 56 ans didier et sa
prétendante numéro un la plantureuse
fatima ça va matra edwards et le
comportement caché direct de fatima
envers didier a créé la polémique
une chose est sûre dès leur premier
rendez-vous la jeune femme a employé les
grands moyens pour séduire l'agriculteur
je veux venir gestion vous dis moi
jamais vraiment de tee-shirts aux roses
et le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
que ça a plutôt bien fonctionné pour
elle il était sous le charme notre
didier et mais non mais doit-on jours de
rtt et louis premier rendez vous ça
parle déjà mariage elle perd pas tant
fatima à l'engraissement arrivé et on
arrivant à la ferme chez didier elle a
vraiment sorti le grand jeu et il a les
yeux revolver mans didier allez allez en
même temps je te fait des massages à
marc charron et a pas trouvé une femme
et oui mais pour certains fatima est
venu avec un plan en tête petit à petit
l'oiseau fait son nid et ce comportement
a beaucoup fait parler dans les médias
certains doutent de sa sincérité envers
didier sur twitter fatima a même vécu un
véritable acharnement je suis deg de
fatima saiah le manipule à aix et che
lire et faire comme s'ils étaient mariés
comme ça il sera mal s'est choisi
l'autre en même temps fatima n'a pas
tenté de cacher ses intentions même
pendant l'émission souvenez vous
j'essaye de le seigneur phare - charme
faire ce qu'on me demande de faire alors
après avoir vu tout ça on est en droit
de se poser une question alors selon
vous pourquoi fatima atistes l otan la
haine sur les réseaux sociaux
on accueille fatima majima
[Musique]
merci beaucoup déplu françois mercier
venu de moi parce que c'est vrai que ça
pas été facile pour vos mois l'émission
vous savez ce que j'en pense je suis pas
fan absolu mais les formidables
merci savez que vous étiez plutôt
amusante là pour le coup ce qui se
passait quelque chose alors on va
revenir point par point sur tout ce
qu'on vous a reproché
bon déjà on dit que vous êtes venus
uniquement pour faire le show non c'est
à dire qu est ce qui fait qu est ce que
vous vouliez vraiment chercher l'amour
dans le pré ce qu'elle veut dire et a
longtemps que je voulais m'inscrire à la
base on savait pas comment ça marche et
et là j'ai tenté et j'ai créé didier et
il y en a plein que 16 ans a merdé ou en
bété comme on dit de me voir là dedans
avec didier
c'est ça que j'ai pas compris mais c'est
vrai que quand alors dray qui est un
montage donc on n'a pas su assister à
toutes les étapes mais c'est vrai que
vous êtes très très très incisif comme
avec dédié bah oui je suis comme ça moi
dans la vie à la wii c'est vrai puis
sont pour l'instant ils sont que l es
tout seul donc ça ça change le
comportement évidemment quand il ya les
deux candidates qui arrivent en même
temps il n'ya pas le même comportement
moi je trouve juste ça très désobligeant
cette polémique pour didier parce que
j'ai l'impression que on pense que
n'importe quelle femme de toute façon ne
pourrait pas être séduite par didier la
fabrègue c'est ça je trouve à damas les
obligeant non moi je trouve les gens
pour didier on peut pourquoi pas être
séduite par didier vous avez écrit mais
pas par hasard qu'il avait créé a dit
mais qu'est ce qui vous a le plus baissé
fait et maintenant nombreux vous avez pu
lire enfin si vous avez vu d'ailleurs
que vous pouvez dire tout ce qu'il ya
sur les réseaux oui c'est fait la
fraction qu'est-ce qui est le plus grand
comme quoi j'avais créé parce que je
voulais son compte en banque que en fait
je voulais sans argent mais moi je
savais qu'au départ il avait rien mais
est-ce qu'on peut être honnête c'est
vrai que fatima s'est fait traiter de
michelot les réseaux sociaux ça pour moi
c'est insupportable parce qu'en plus
vous êtes assez honnête vous dites que
vous vous démarriez mai soit parce
qu'une femme de se marier que c'est une
niche tôt et en plus c'est vrai il est
agriculteur on sait à quel point c'est
compliqué c'est un métier c'est
difficile de gagner de l'argent c'est
pas un footballeur non plus ne vois pas
pourquoi on la traite de michto vois pas
le rapport
et c'est vrai que vous lui dites
plusieurs fois je veux me marier je veux
me marier pas moi aussi quand je vois m
marié se marient vous avez raison vous
dis bravo énormément choqué comme
attaque quasi personnel contre vous je
voulais vous le dire c'est le fait que
quasiment on vous a dit que vous vouliez
vous marier pour obtenir des papas et
moi et vous vous posez une question
directe est ce qu'on vous a accusé de ça
parce que vous prénommé fathi ben voilà
c'est ce que j'ai compris moi est ce que
si vous voyez non heureusement que je
reprendrai les français n'aiment pas de
française c'est à l'uci de l'essence à
ses blessures
mais c'est tout vu et je suis désolé moi
ce que j'ai vu dans l'émission c'est que
pour l'instant à lui apporter du bon
temps oui c'est le cavaliere bien avec
vous tant qu'étude jeu c'était la
question que j'ai posée mais qu'est ce
que vous aimez chez didier j'ai dit
diane fait quand j'ai écrit en fait j'ai
vu qu'on avait des mêmes points communs
c'est quelqu'un qui a la joie de vivre a
même rigolé il est comme moi je me suis
sentie comme si cette nuit c'était moi
c'est pareil ça creuse moi j'aime pas
les gens que admettant il rigole pas il
samedi spa sais pas comment on faisait
longtemps que vous vouliez vous inscrire
ça veut dire que lors des précédentes
saisons vous aviez déjà des vues sur
l'aja j'avais vu moi à l'époque que
j'avais vu des gens que c'était mais
qu'ils en étaient heureux sont mariés
c'est vrai que je regardais son magasin
en ville est dans le pré j'ai dit
pourquoi pas moi pour lui pourquoi je te
retourne pas ma chance
est ce qu'aujourd'hui ils l'amour est
dans le pré vous avoir plus de positif
que de négatif 1 ben oui mais c'est
positif on peut pas on peut pas dévoiler
la après je peux pas dévoiler m la faim
moi j'ai une question quand même une
question pendant que le domaine se pose
et je vais la pause et didier a donc dit
qu'il était plus haut oui alors est-ce
qu'il était plus haut
attendez moi c'est quand même important
non mais c'est la vache est déjà discuté
avec lui je suis demandé si c'était vrai
qualité plus haut il m'a dit que c'est
pas vrai avait connu des femmes alors on
nous aurait menti contessa et m'a dit je
sais pas quand je vous dis que tout
n'est pas clair dans la production de
leur était bonne devrait donc ils vont
ils vous ont demandé ils ont demandé de
dire qu'il était plus au décès lui quand
tu verras qu'il était plus haut mais les
papilles sont moi il m'a dit la prévenue
des femmes d'un service afrique à
vérifier vous même c'est trop triste
pour cette pour 7h marque très important
dans le magal est ce que j'apprécie chez
vous parce que moi je gère déjà les
réalités et effectivement où il est un
peu une télé ralité ce numéro et chinois
pas se mentir
vous mettez en danger que votre naturel
c'est à dire qu'en fait c'est tellement
naturel et c'est ce que veulent les
productions aujourd'hui donc bravo à
vous et je pense que vous êtes sincère
moi j'ai aucun doute sur vannes c'est
parce que justement vous ne réfléchit
pas vous ne réfléchissez pas pardon à
tous qui vous tous qui va vous arriver
après et vous n'avez pas eu peur de vous
mettre en danger en étant juste tels que
vous êtes et vous en fichez totalement
de ce qui peut se dire mais vu et
franchement bravo et voilà aujourd'hui
mais vraiment et je l'avais vraiment à
un croche avec avait avec didier vous
avez un croche avec dédié aux accroches
parisien
de coeur avec eux je n'aurais pas écrit
honnêtement à vous de bien des maux d'un
coup de foudre je me suis sentie ge il
est pareil que moi c'est quelqu'un qui
aime rigoler c'est quelqu'un que simple
j'aime la vie j'ai dit oui je vais lui
j'ai pas écrit aux autres c'est pas vous
cherchez un agriculteur n'importe quoi
vous savez en fait en fait vous cherchez
à trouver l'âme soeur
j'ai cherché noise la russia mais c'est
vrai qu'on me suis dit je vais marier
oui monsieur direct écosse ah bah là là
là tu n'as pas compris voulais je trouve
quand même que c'est étonnant que l'on
reproche à une femme qui va dans une
émission de dating pour se marier de
dire qu'elle veut se marier et ses
intentions du tour c'est vrai que c'est
vrai que dans ce combat je vois dans la
mort et d'entrée un gars c'est pas
toujours aussi direct c'est vrai que là
fatima mère dans votre comportement vous
étiez très très engagé entre nous avec
vos pairs pas pourquoi on sait sur ces
collines c'est pas pour un soir à la seu
tu veux ou tu veux pas moins de 3 vous
êtes quand même au coeur de la polémique
à des attaques directes on n'entend pas
beaucoup la chaîne où la production vous
défendre est-ce que vous avez
l'impression d'être un peu abandonné
lâchés dans la nature et 8 passes par
sama dépend du style moi même qui nous
défend un vase et moi et ma famille et
vous leur en voulez vous en a donné
comme ça ne pas vous défendre ne pas
monter au créneau c'est moi parce que je
savais ce qui m'a fait le plus mal au
coeur je n'ai pas de 14 ans et le poivre
eastleigh souvent dans les sites classés
je suis étonné quand même que là pour le
coup on en a déjà parlé sur ce dans
cette émission mais les chaînes et les
producteurs on a une responsabilité
parce qu'on met des gens à l'antenne on
avait parlé longuement pour nous donc
j'ai pu faire dans passé mais là on vous
sent quand même touché vrai été ni
appelé par la chaîne n'est pas la
production vous allez c'est comme ça
vivre cette histoire tout seul seul le
oui c'est pas normal jamais l'émission
est diffusée sa part une ou deux femmes
a pu les voir si tout va bien
et voilà mais là je vous en jeu ne sont
pas bien on fait facilement
vous avez touché parce que parce que
votre guerre sont évidemment il est pour
rien et dire comment leur expliquer à
votre fils que vous allez faire cette
émission parce que c'est une démarche
non mais ça va mieux mais pas tellement
il était mal puisqu'au moins je veux
dire moi pour avoir vu les premières
images est ce que vous êtes satisfaite
du montage qui était faite de l'émission
oui oui c'est bien moi on me dit mon
travail est tout on m'a dit fatima
sétois d'invités comme ça bien la
production vous à pas forcés à jouer un
rôle en allemand c'est à moi de savoir
salaires ces femmes importance avec là
on a peut présenter mes salaires une
affaire sérieuse
on vous sent quand même blessées
heurtées oui ça a été quand même un peu
un peu secoué pas par la fête qu'est ce
que vous allez me dire aux gens qui vous
regardent ceux qui vont suivre
l'émission on sait pas évidemment ce
qu'ils valent en esquivant ne doit pas
vous dire vous nous raconter la fin va
pas vous comment allez vous spolier
comme on dit vous spoiler spolie des
trois portes et qu'elles ont envie de
dire des franchement les gens passent et
les gens' les internautes vous savez les
internautes ne sont pas de chez eux
c'est déjà proust et franchement il chez
eux y critique tout le monde que ça soit
moi vous n'importe qui mais c'est des
gens qui connaissent pas la vie et la
vie des autres ouais franchement moi je
trouve que c'est dégueulasse et dans la
rue les gens réagissent pas comme ça son
sein par une nana la vie de gens pour
rencontre des gens sérieux qui viennent
vers moi et m'a embrassé il me plaît on
peut vous faire un bisou et tout ça
franchement que les gens que je vois
dans la rue ils me remonte le moral
ouais c'est vrai mais les gens qui sont
nés vers les réseaux c'est même pas la
peine
ce canada puisqu'elle était acculé le
parce que là où se regarde un peu triste
qu'est-ce qui vous êtes papa blessé
apparemment bon évidemment il est
critique avant pourquoi s'être abello et
ça c'est pas mal ça va pas non
lors de ses deux médailles à une bonne
descente
moi je pense surtout à évidemment c'est
terrible ça on peut c'est gratuit c'est
stupide crâne plus aucun intérêt
après j'étais là pour le graet et ses
sous que je lui ai écrit pour son argent
j'ai dû me le rien il a rien du tout
j'aurais voulu de l'argent j'aurais créé
un agriculteur qui est appelé à relancer
lui au bon sens veut pas savoir en même
temps il ya rien mais on voulait un bébé
vu la voiture qu'il a il a rien donc
c'est lui c'est lui qui vous a plu voilà
c'est didier voilà alors eu de suite oui
elle a écrit parce qu'elle veut son
argent mais les papiers alors que nous
qui vous suivent vont un peu dans cette
aventure
est-ce que commence avec un bon on va
pas dire mais ça ça avance bien quand
même tout ça avec lui sur ben oui mais
après je peux rien vous dire
mais bon ça avance bien ous avons signé
ça avance bien plus ou bien bien bien là
ça va plus ça vous rappelle andy
bah ouais mais là
[Applaudissements]
savonnez me dis que ça avance bien bien
on lui souhaite bon raymond important
c'est qu'elle a dit moi j'ai bien aimé
quand as tu as dit les gens au travail
se tutoie les gens au travail on dit que
tu étais comme ça et pas très sage si
les gens autour de toi te dise bata pas
changé c'est comme ça que tu es
réellement ça c'est super important ce
qui se passe sur les réseaux sociaux
voilà essaye de mettre de côté toi oui
sinon mais à ton fils aussi de dire par
là et comme tu as dit les gens il sort
pas de ces gens oui c'est des profils
assez albator sais pas qui c'est les
gens qui critiquent tout le monde est
beau en tout cas c'est bien d'être venu
tu as l'air si tu as l'air vachement
sympa vraiment l'un de leurs jokers la
guerre des bobos on va embrasser visée
parce que est plutôt sympa et c'est un
peu la surdépendance et j'ai vraiment
hâte de voir si la vie c'était bien plus
nos gardiens
[Applaudissements]